el cáncer de páncreas es una enfermedad
que comienza en uno de los órganos
digestivos el páncreas está ubicado
justo debajo del estómago
Su páncreas está compuesto de una cabeza
cuerpo y cola
contiene dos tipos de células
principales un tipo llamadas células
exocrinas producen enzimas digestivas
que son segregadas en tubos llamados
conductos
las enzimas viajando a través de los
conductos eventualmente dan a parar en
su intestino delgado donde ayudan en la
digestión el otro tipo de célula
pancreática es llamada la célula
endocrina las células endocrinas están
amontonadas en grupos conocidos Como
islotes de langerhans
las células producen las hormonas de la
insulina y el glucagón los cuales son
liberados en el torrente sanguíneo para
ayudar a controlar su nivel de azúcar en
la sangre
el cáncer de páncreas comienza como
mutaciones de las células pancreáticas
causando que estas crezcan muy rápida e
incontrolablemente
las células mutadas a menudo se juntan
para formar tumores los cuales pueden
interferir con la función normal del
páncreas como este tumor la mayoría de
los cánceres de páncreas Se forman en
los conductos y son llamados
adenocarcinomas o tumores exocrinos
los tumores endocrinos que se
desarrollan de los islotes de langerhans
son mucho menos comunes
su médico le recomendará un tratamiento
en base al tipo de célula involucrada
ubicación y etapa de su cáncer
el tratamiento puede incluir cirugía
radiación quimioterapia terapia dirigida
o una combinación de tratamientos
hay tres tipos de opciones quirúrgicas
para tratar el cáncer de páncreas
durante un procedimiento de whipple
también llamado pancreatoduo denectomía
su cirujanos retirará la cabeza de su
páncreas su vesícula biliar y porciones
de su conducto biliar común intestino
delgado y estómago las estructuras
restantes eran dispuestas de tal forma
que permitan una digestión continua
en una páncreatectomía total su cirujano
retirará su páncreas entero el conducto
biliar común la vesícula biliar el vaso
y los nódulos linfáticos así como
porciones de su estómago e intestino
delgado
durante una páncreatectomía distal su
cirujano retirará el cuerpo y la cola
del páncreas al igual que su vaso
la radiación o radioterapia utiliza
Rayos de alta energía para matar las
células cancerígenas solo en el área
tratada
si la radiación se origina de una
máquina en el exterior de su cuerpo el
tratamiento es llamado radioterapia de
as externo
la radioterapia ubicada en el interior
de su cuerpo en forma de semillas
radiactivas es llamada braquiterapia o
radioterapia interna
la quimioterapia usa fármacos para
detener el progreso del cáncer ya sea
matando las células o evitando que
crezcan más la quimioterapia sistemática
es tomada por la boca o mediante una
inyección permitiendo que los fármacos
viajen a través del torrente sanguíneo
para llegar hasta las células
cancerígenas en todo el cuerpo la
quimioterapia regional involucra la
inyección del fármaco en las arterias
alrededor del tumor permitiendo el
alcance inmediato a las células
cancerígenas
las terapias dirigidas se enfocan en
anomalías genéticas específicas de
células cancerígenas
se piensa que una terapia dirigida
erlotinip detiene el crecimiento del
tumor bloqueando las señales químicas
que inician el crecimiento y la división
de las células